Intro
This is a video for anyone who already knows
what eigenvalues and eigenvectors are, and
who might enjoy a quick way to compute them
in the case of 2x2 matrices. If you’re unfamiliar
with eigenvalues, take a look at this video
which introduces them.
You can skip ahead if you just want to see
the trick, but if possible I’d like you
to rediscover it for yourself, so for that
let’s lay down a little background.
As a quick reminder, if the effect of a linear
transformation on a given vector is to scale
it by some constant, we call it an "eigenvector"
of the transformation, and we call the relevant
scaling factor the corresponding "eigenvalue,"
often denoted with the letter lambda. When
you write this as an equation and you rearrange
a little bit, what you see is that if the
number lambda is an eigenvalue of a matrix
A, then the matrix (A minus lambda times the
identity) must send some nonzero vector, namely
the corresponding eigenvector, to the zero
vector, which in turn means the determinant
of this modified matrix must be 0.
Okay, that’s all a little bit of a mouthful
to say, but again, I’m assuming all of this
is review for anyone watching.
So, the usual way to compute eigenvalues,
how I used to do it, and how I believe most
students are taught to carry it out, is to
subtract the unknown value lambda off the
diagonals and then solve for when the determinant
equals 0.
Doing this always involves a few steps to
expand out and simplify to get a clean quadratic
polynomial, what's known as the “characteristic
polynomial” of the matrix. The eigenvalues
are the roots of this polynomial. So to find
them you have to apply the quadratic formula,
which itself typically requires one or two
more steps of simplification.
Honestly, the process isn’t terrible. But
at least for 2x2 matrices, there’s a much
more direct way to get at this answer. And
if you want to rediscover this trick, there
are only three relevant facts you need to
know, each of which is worth knowing in its
own right and can help you with other problem-solving.
Number 1: The trace of a matrix, which is
the sum of these two diagonal entries, is
equal to the sum of the eigenvalues. Or another
way to phrase it, more useful for our purposes,
is that the mean of the two eigenvalues is
the same as the mean of these two diagonal
entries.
Number 2: The determinant of a matrix, our
usual ad-bc formula, is equal to the product
of the two eigenvalues. And this should kind
of make sense if you understand that eigenvalues
describe how much an operator stretches space
in a particular direction and that the determinant
describes how much an operator scales areas
(or volumes) as a whole.
Now before getting to the third fact, notice
how you can essentially read these first two
values out of the matrix without really writing
much down. Take this matrix here as an example.
Straight away you can know that the mean of
the eigenvalues is the same as the mean of
8 and 6, which is 7. Likewise, most linear
algebra students are pretty well-practiced
at finding the determinant, which in this
case works out to be 48 - 8 So right away
you know that the product of our two eigenvalues
is 40.
Now take a moment to see how you can derive
what will be our third relevant fact, which
is how to recover two numbers when you know
their mean and you know their product.
Here, let's focus on this example. You know
the two values are evenly spaced around 7,
so they look like 7 plus or minus something;
let’s call that something "d" for distance.
You also know that the product of these two
numbers is 40. Now to find d, notice that
this product expands really nicely, it works
out as a difference of squares. So from there,
you can directly find d: d^2 is 7^2 - 40,
or 9, which means d itself is 3.
In other words, the two values for this very
specific example work out to be 4 and 10.
But our goal is a quick trick, and you wouldn’t
want to think this through each time, so let’s
wrap up what we just did in a general formula.
For any mean, m and product, p, the distance
squared is always going to be m^2 - p. This
gives the third key fact, which is that when
two numbers have a mean m and a product p,
you can write those two numbers as m ± sqrt(m^2
- p)
This is decently fast to rederive on the fly
if you ever forget it, and it’s essentially
just a rephrasing of the difference of squares
formula. But even still it’s a fact worth
memorizing so that you have it at the tip
of your fingers.
In fact, my friend Tim from the channel acapellascience
wrote us a quick jingle to make it a little
more memorable.
m plus or minus squaaaare root of me squared
minus p (ping!)
Let me show you how this works, say for the
matrix [[3,1], [4,1]]. You start by bringing
to mind the formula, maybe stating it all
in your head. But when you write it down,
you fill in the appropriate values of m and
p as you go. So in this example, the mean
of the eigenvalues is the same as the mean
of 3 and 1, which is 2. So the thing you start
writing is 2 ± sqrt(2^2 - …). Then the
product of the eigenvalues is the determinant,
which in this example is 3*1 - 1*4, or -1.
So that’s the final thing you fill in. This
means the eigenvalues are 2±sqrt(5). You
might recognize that this is the same matrix
I was using at the beginning, but notice how
much more directly we can get at the answer.
Here, try another one. This time the mean
of the eigenvalues is the same as the mean
of 2 and 8, which is 5. So again, you start
writing out the formula but this time writing
5 in place of m [song]. And then the determinant
is 2*8 - 7*1, or 9. So in this example, the
eigenvalues look like 5 ± sqrt(16), which
simplifies even further as 9 and 1.
You see what I mean about how you can basically
just start writing down the eigenvalues while
staring at the matrix? It’s typically just
the tiniest bit of simplifying at the end.
Honestly, I’ve found myself using this trick
a lot when I’m sketching quick notes related
to linear algebra and want to use small matrices
as examples. I’ve been working on a video
about matrix exponents, where eigenvalues
pop up a lot, and I realized it’s just very
handy if students can read off the eigenvalues
from small examples without losing the main
line of thought by getting bogged down in
a different calculation.
As another fun example, take a look at this
set of three different matrices, which come
up a lot in quantum mechanics, they're known
as the Pauli spin matrices. If you know quantum
mechanics, you’ll know that the eigenvalues
of matrices are highly relevant to the physics
they describe, and if you don’t know quantum
mechanics, let this just be a little glimpse
of how these computations are actually relevant
to real applications.
The mean of the diagonal in all three cases
is 0, so the mean of the eigenvalues in all
cases is 0, which makes our formula look especially
simple.
What about the products of the eigenvalues,
the determinants of these matrices? For the
first one, it’s 0 - 1 or -1. The second
also looks like 0 - 1, but it takes a moment
more to see because of the complex numbers.
And the final one looks like -1 - 0. So in
all cases, the eigenvalues simplify to be
±1. Although in this case, you really don’t
need the formula to find two values if you
know theyr'e evenly spaced around 0 and their
product is -1.
If you’re curious, in the context of quantum
mechanics, these matrices describe observations
you might make about a particle's spin in
the x, y or z directions. The fact that their
eigenvalues are ±1 corresponds with the idea
that the values for the spin that you would
observe would be either entirely in one direction
or entirely in another, as opposed to something
continuously ranging in between. Maybe you’d
wonder how exactly this works, or why you
would use 2x2 matrices that have complex numbers
to describe spin in three dimensions. And
those would be fair questions, just outside
the scope of what I want to talk about here.
You know it’s funny, I wrote this section
because I wanted some case where you have
2x2 matrices that are not just toy examples
or homework problems, ones where they actually
come up in practice, and quantum mechanics
is great for that. But the thing is after
I made it I realized that the whole example
kind of undercuts the point I’m trying to
make. For these specific matrices, when you
use the traditional method, the one with characteristic
polynomials, it’s essentially just as fast;
it might actually faster. I mean, take a look
a the first one: The relevant determinant
directly gives you a characteristic polynomial
of lambda^2 - 1, and clearly, that has roots
of plus and minus 1. Same answer when you
do the second matrix, lambda^2 - 1. And as
for the last matrix, forget about doing any
computations, traditional or otherwise, it’s
already a diagonal matrix, so those diagonal
entries are the eigenvalues!
However, the example is not totally lost to
our cause. Where you will actually feel the
speed up is in the more general case where
you take a linear combination of these three
matrices and then try to compute the eigenvalues.
You might write this as a times the first
one, plus b times the second, plus c times
the third. In quantum mechanics, this would
describe spin observations in a general direction
of a vector with coordinates [a, b, c]. More
specifically, you should assume this vector
is normalized, meaning a^2 + b^2 + c^2 = 1.
When you look at this new matrix, it’s immediate
to see that the mean of the eigenvalues is
still zero, and you might also enjoy pausing
for a brief moment to confirm that the product
of those eigenvalues is still -1, and then
from there concluding what the eigenvalues
must be. And this time, the characteristic
polynomial approach would be by comparison
a lot more cumbersome, definitely harder to
do in your head.
To be clear, using the mean-product formula
is not fundamentally different from finding
roots of the characteristic polynomial; I
mean, it can't be, they're solving the same
problem. One way to think about this, actually,
is that the mean-product formula is a nice
way to solve quadratic in general (and some
viewers of the channel may recognize this).
This about it: When you’re trying to find
the roots of a quadratic given its coefficients,
that's another situation where you know the
sum of two values, and you also know their
product, but you’re trying to recover the
original two values.
Specifically, if the polynomial is normalized
so that this leading coefficient is 1, then
the mean of the roots will be -½ times this
linear coefficient, which is -1 times the
sum of those roots. For the example on the
screen that makes the mean 5. And the product
of the roots is even easier, it’s just the
constant term no adjustments needed. So from
there, you would apply the mean product formula
and that gives you the roots.
On the one hand, you could think of this as
a lighter-weight version of the traditional
quadratic formula. But the real advantage
is that it's fewer symbols to memorize, it's
that each one of them carries more meaning
with it.
The whole point of this eigenvalue trick is
that because you can read out the mean and
product directly from looking at the matrix,
you don't need to go through the intermediate
step of setting up the characteristic polynomial.
You can jump straight to writing down the
roots without ever explicitly thinking about
what the polynomial looks like. But to do
that we need a version of the quadratic formula
where the terms carry some kind of meaning.
I realize that this is a very specific trick,
for a very specific audience, but it’s something
I wish I knew in college, so if you happen
to know any students who might benefit from
this, consider sharing it with them.
The hope is that it’s not just one more
thing to memorize, but that the framing reinforces
some other nice facts worth knowing, like
how the trace and determinant relate to eigenvalues.
If you want to prove those facts, by the way,
take a moment to expand out the characteristic
polynomial for a general matrix, and think
hard about the meaning of each of these coefficients.
Many thanks to Tim, for ensuring that this
mean-product formula will stay stuck in all
of our heads for at least a few months. If
you don’t know about acapellascience, please
do check it out. "The Molecular Shape of You",
in particular, is one of the greatest things
on the internet.